STEPHANIE WONG:
Today we're talking
about free training, automation,
and optimizing storage costs.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
There's not much
better than free.
Since the start
of the year, we've
introduced a number of
opportunities for you
to grow your skills, and we
wanted to bring them together
into one place.
Whether you're just getting
started on the Cloud
or are looking for ways to
challenge yourself and collect
skills badges, bookmark
this collection of training
opportunities and
check back regularly
Automation is now
available for everyone
with AppSheet automation.
AppSheet, our no-code
development platform,
leverages Google AI
to make it easier
to automate business
processes, letting
you focus more on high-impact
work and less on manual tasks.
Check out the Getting Started
video and reclaim your time.
Storage is a
critical component of
any cloud-based infrastructure.
Without a place to store
and serve your data,
databases won't work,
compute can't run,
and networks have nowhere to
put the data they're carrying.
So it's no surprise
that you want
to make sure you're
optimizing your storage costs.
This guide will give
you advice on what
to look for and identify
ways you can save some cash.
Sometimes a picture is
worth a thousand words,
and that's where these
cheat sheets come in handy.
Our own Priyanka Vergadia
has built a number of guides
that help developers visually
navigate critical decisions,
whether it's determining the
best way to move to the cloud
or deciding on the
best storage options.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.